I'll let you ask me one question what
question you ask three I'd get scared
okay question number one I'm gonna be a
sundae area because I can't be okay
question number one you have gone from
being fairly unknown in the crypto space
I don't say like when I first met you I
was like who's this pop guy to now
people talk about the pump as though
it's an adjective which I love like so
ridiculous
so you have engaged in a very effective
growth marketing strategy yep
what's your thought process there so the
man the pump tell us more what one is I
have a very unique advantage in that
I've worked on growth at large
technology companies right so I
understand how I understand the pump
yeah I understand how a lot of the
algorithms work etc I think that too is
I'm a huge believer that audience is
currency right in terms of if you have
an audience it doesn't have to be
everyone but if you're able to find
like-minded individuals you can use that
to your advantage
right and for those around you to the to
the advantage as well and then I think
the third thing is and I get a lot of
[ __ ] frankly for this is I think that a
lot of the people in this space are very
heavy and very talented the technology
side and so they tend to be I think they
are but there's a lot of intellectual
[ __ ] like you're wrong well that's
every industry but probably even more
here right and so what you get is you
get very like technical jargon you get
like the overly you know just kind of
conversation and so when I solve this I
said you know look our our our business
is to manage money for investors right
mainly institutional investors and help
them get access to what we really think
of as the digital age so I even the
blockchain age but we think that
blockchain and cryptocurrency Bitcoin
accessor is like 90 95 percent of that
today but I would argue that things like
Robin Hood or Robo advisors etc all are
you know an analogous to this world and
so the one area that I saw that nobody
was doing a good job of or least not
doing it
scale was can you take these highly
technical concepts and basically boil
them down to the simplest form and then
share them with an audience and so it's
not really going after our hearts and
minds right it cuz I think that that's a
piece of it right as you is if you do
this successfully you may get some
hearts and minds but really it was just
I'm not smart enough to look at a very
technical white paper and understand
every single detail I want to reject
that notion okay I think people in this
space are like oh well I'm not technical
oh I'm not smart enough yes you are like
growth marketing is a highly technical
field it is every field has a technical
component to it and I categorically
reject the notion that being technical
in a non engineering fields not valuable
I think you're just just just to clarify
it's not that I think that non-technical
people aren't valuable what I think is
that if you sit me in a room and you say
hey explain you know zero knowledge
proof and you bring an engineer in
they're going to be able to explain it
better than I am at a very deep
technical level now the difference is
that's exactly their audience is other
people like them who understand that
deep technical language my audience is
very different